[Music]
in the early 1900's on the island of
Crete British archaeologist sir Arthur
Evans uncovered nearly 3,000 tablets
inscribed with strange symbols he
thought these symbols represented the
language spoken by Europe's oldest
civilization their meaning would elude
scholars for 50 years
Evans discovered these tablets amid the
colorful frescoes and maze-like hallways
of the palace of Colossus he called the
civilization Minoan after the mythical
creature and ruler King Minos he thought
the script dubbed linear be represented
them in Owen language and scholars all
over the world came up with their own
theories was it the lost language of the
Etruscans or perhaps it represented an
early form of Basque the mystery
intensified because Evans guarded the
tablets closely only 200 of the
inscriptions were published during his
lifetime but he couldn't decipher the
script however he did make two accurate
observations the tablets were
administrative records and the script
was a syllabary where each symbol
represented both a consonant and a vowel
mixed with characters that each
represented a whole word Evans worked on
linear B for three decades before a
scholar from Brooklyn New York named
Alice Kober set out to solve the mystery
Kobra was a professor of classics at
Brooklyn College
when few women held such positions to
help in her quest she taught herself
many languages knowledge she knew she
would need to decipher linear B for the
next two decades she analyzed the
symbols working from the few available
inscriptions she recorded how often each
symbol appeared then she recorded how
frequently each symbol appeared next to
another she stored her findings on scrap
paper in cigarette cartons because
writing supplies were scarce during the
Second World War by analyzing these
frequencies she discovered that linear b
relied on word endings to give it
sentences grammar from this she began to
build a chart of the relations between
the signs coming closer than anyone
before to deciphering linear B but she
died probably of cancer in 1950 at the
age of 43 while cobra was analyzing the
Colossus tablets an architect named
Michael Ventris was also working to
crack linear b he had become obsessed
with linear b as a schoolboy
after hearing evans speak he even worked
on deciphering the script while serving
in world war ii after the war Ventress
belt on koba's grid using a newly
published cache of linear b inscriptions
excavated from a different archeological
site called pilus on mainland greece his
real breakthrough came when he compared
the tablets from Pylos with those from
canosa's and saw that certain words
appeared on tablets from one site but
not the other he wondered if those words
represented the names of places specific
to each location
he knew that over centuries place names
tend to remain constant and decided to
compare linear b to an ancient syllabary
from the island of Cyprus the Cypriot
script was used hundreds of years after
linear B but some of the symbols were
similar he wondered if the sounds would
be similar to when Ventress plugged some
of the sounds of the Cypriot syllabary
into the linear b inscriptions he came
up with the word Conesus the name of the
city where Evans had discovered his
tablets in a domino effect
Ventris unraveled linear B with each
word revealing more clearly that the
language of linear B was not Minoan but
Greek Ventris died in a car crash four
years later at the age of 34 but his
discovery rewrote a chapter of history
Evans had insisted that the Minoans
conquered the mainland Greeks and that
was why examples of linear B were found
on the mainland but the discovery that
linear b represented greek and not
Minoan showed that the opposite had
happened mainland Greeks invaded Crete
and adopted the Minoan script for their
own language but the story isn't over
yet the actual language of the Minoans
represented by another script called
linear a has yet to be deciphered it
remains a mystery at least for now
these aren't the only unsolved
linguistic mysteries find out more about
the book that no one can read with this
video and see if you can crack the code
that has stumped scholars for decades
[Music]